what gravy has been hooked on heroin
since he was 13
he's calm and measured as he tells me a
story about his childhood his stepfather
and how he's chased heroin ever since
used to common everyday water me stupid
named Walker walk at the water and then
he fairly give me Sonny
he be just open a pathway to depart walk
with the dog and I may not have any
sensory for shame to say this is a night
bus for lost souls and it offers
Glasgow's drug addicts some respite from
the epidemic outside because Glasgow is
gripped by heroin and it's killing more
people than ever different William read
Pat's been clean for 20 months this
though is a reminder of what drugs did
to him and he told me about the time he
died twice in one night after taking the
heroin substitute methadone took too
much Nate on volume and
got arrested for a warm end up just into
a station overdose from the back it was
fun gosh the hospital died in the
backyard learnt how to get transfer out
the game doesn't host ball diving and
ambulance again you know in 2001 Nate 21
year olds desperate for a solution the
Scottish government wants to take
control of drug policy away from central
government but so far Westminster has
refused okay so the patients come
through from the waiting area into this
main clinical space which is the
injecting area this is about as far as
Scotland can go on its own right now
here addicts can get
pharmaceutical-grade heroin for free and
injected here themselves
purpose of the mirror on the wall is so
that the nurse has great visibility of
the hole injecting episode but what
clinicians really want to do here is
allow addicts to bring their own drugs
rather than inject on the streets but
that would require power to be devolved
to Scotland do you think you would see a
significant reduction in drug deaths if
you were able to have that power we
think there's a very strong evidence
base that supports the likelihood of
that being very beneficial we have made
representations to Westminster
government to make the appropriate legal
changes unfortunately that's not being
forthcoming so far but the case for it
remains as strong as ever
but not everyone agrees with this
approach a few miles outside of Glasgow
is the Haven a rehab center run by a
Christian charity where abstinence forms
the foundation for recovery Oh heroin
just came on like a week ago one VOA
it's just their old over drugs took a
backseat trucks ruled your life Leon
suffered a drug overdose and have to be
brought back to life
shortly before coming here nine months
ago he doesn't think providing a space
for addicts to inject is the answer
that's right you do short term but long
term it's not going to be an answer I
told you stick gave drug addicts dog
doesn't know the answer is the drug
policy of the moment working I would say
no if somebody is being prescribed
methadone let's have a strategy to not
part them on it but to get them off it
let's give them an alternative over a
period of time there is a chance for
them to be drug-free Scotland's drug
epidemic is killing three people each
day and as politicians chased their own
fix
Glasgow's dispossessed are dying chasing
there's Nick Martin Sky News Glasgow